hey we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and your boom what's up everyone welcome
to simulation I'm your host Don Saki on
super excited to be talking about memory
skills training we have Chester Santos
joining us on the show hello thanks for
having me great huh I'm really happy to
be here Alan back on for round 2 with
Chester so excited Chester is one of the
first guests we had on the show like a
year and a half ago maybe it was within
the first ten episodes or so and now
it's almost 500 of these and I'm so
happy to have you back
Chester you like authored a book in the
meanwhile you've been touring the world
giving talks on memory skills training
so for those of donar Chester's
background is a us memory champion and
memory skills expert that helps people
around the world to unlock their full
memory potential he's also the author of
instant memory training for success and
mastering memory techniques to turn your
brain from a sieve to a sponge and you
can find the links in the bio below
Chester Santos calm as all says LinkedIn
Twitter profiles and the mastering
memory book
Chester let's start things off by asking
you what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world
yeah so my thoughts on the direction of
our world obviously we are very nowadays
tech focused world right we're a very
technology driven Society and you know
my worry is that we might not be you
know we think technology can solve
everything you know we're relying on
technology to solve all of our problems
but we need to just be a little bit wary
about you know we need to remain focused
also on human development right we need
to be focused on our personal
development at all times it's still very
important and it will always be
important I think we're living in an age
now of digital dependency is what I like
to call it I gave a talk at the end of
last year at the International Festival
of brilliant minds on the danger of
digital dependency and that is that we
are outsourcing not only our memory but
other mental functions to electronic
devices soul are losing those abilities
I always emphasize that it is incredible
what these devices can help us do and
they are incredibly useful to us in our
business
personal life nowadays in school as well
there's a lot that they can do for us
but I just want people to be aware that
we need to not just completely outsource
our mental abilities to those devices we
need to continue to use our brains
continue to exercise our brains or I
think we're going to find out that some
big problems develop down the line yeah
that's a really good way to put it in
especially on this a deeper time
perspective where we have really just in
the last 50 years been in the last
couple decades they've become a
ubiquitous these computing technologies
and prior to that throughout the whole
historical development of the human
species we've never been able to do
things well we had a book to potential
right things to store yet our our
memories our thoughts but with these
devices now in the way that the
attention economics are working we're
really working into some grounds that we
don't aren't really that aware of that
future impacts of and I'm I'm happy that
you bring that up as the direction of
our world cuz in a little bit maybe
towards the end I'll want to talk to you
about the future of us interacting with
the technology and working on our own
human development our own biological
development I won't really do wonder
what's happening to the brain as we
offset so much of our memories to the
devices and then what is actually
happening like neurophysiological II
inside of our brains and how much harder
is it making it to do things like
remember someone's name or to remember a
string of things that can help us in a
conversation or presentation or any of
these things yeah it's really
interesting to think about the actual
Physiol physiology the change is taking
place in the brain wouldn't be my area
it's gonna be probably more doctor
Ghazali who I think you've had on this
this show him and I have given some
presentations together in the past he
would probably better be able to address
the physiology what I address in my
presentations are more the skills like
the abilities like remembering phone
numbers for instance we all used to be
able to remember the phone numbers of so
many friends family members we could
easily dial those from memory I remember
growing up my parents would give me
emergency phone numbers that they
thought were important for me to know we
all could do that but nowadays really
you give someone one phone number and
they feel paralyzed like they have no
hope of remembering even that one number
it's getting so bad that there are a lot
of people out there nowadays that don't
even know their own phone number so it's
a really good example of the use it or
lose it principle and I think it
illustrates one one thing that happens
when you really outsource your memory to
these electro
devices another one that isn't
necessarily something I don't talk about
it that often or address it with my
types of trainings although it could be
applicable and that is navigation right
so you're finding now because everyone's
becoming dependent on GPS
you're just not learning your city right
you just aren't learning the streets
anymore how to navigate New York City
taxi drivers were at one point world
famous for their memory ability so much
so that universities were doing research
on their brains but nowadays you get
into a taxi and if the network is down
you just have to sit there they have to
Reese in a taxi where they have to
restart their phone and everything
because they also they're not learning
the streets anymore they no longer know
how to navigate because they've been
completely dependent on these electronic
devices
uber and lyft it's even a little bit
worse because they never put forth that
effort to really look so you have
basically you have people that have been
driving uber and lyft in a city for
maybe many years now and if something's
wrong with the app you really you have
to sit there nobody knows how to get
anywhere right so it's just another I
think example that people can relate to
and it illustrates a little bit of that
danger and completely shutting off your
brain to just let these devices do
everything for you right
and maybe one of the arguments that
people are making is that now that I
don't have to store so many of the phone
numbers or the maps of the streets that
I can then fill my mind with new things
the new technologies that are at the
cutting edge and that could potentially
be part of the case but also we do very
easily see that if I used to be able to
take a phone number or even a pattern of
turning on streets and remember it
really quickly but now it's so much more
difficult for me to do that how is that
impacting all the other aspects of
memory of my life exactly yeah exactly
that's exactly what what I'm trying to
get across there and I wanted to address
that issue that you brought up it's it's
a separate issue
something that I hear people say so
often but in reality are they filling
their brains up with all that new
knowledge about the new debt they're not
they're also outsourcing that to devices
right but really wanna what I want to
hit on here is that classic excuse that
I hear oh I don't want to fill up my
brain with all this useless information
really I'm sorry to say and be blunt
that's just laziness talking right
that's really all it is people are just
being lazy not committing certain things
to memory if there is truly a limit to
human memory we are not going to find it
in our lifetimes right you know about
some of the demonstrations that I've
done with thousands of pieces of data
right there are people that have
memorized you know people used to be
able to memorize entire volumes of
ancient texts even right so there isn't
really a limit to human memory and in
fact I think it's important for me to
stress that how memory and learning
works it's the complete opposite of what
people are thinking right so in fact the
more that you learn the easier it
becomes to learn new things because
learning and memory always comes down to
creating a connection in your mind
between something new that you are
trying to learn and something that you
already know so in fact the more that
you know the easier it's going to be to
learn things so this concept this idea
of I don't want to fill my head with
this usually that actually doesn't make
any sense at all and it's really it's
just an excuse so you do actually want
to take in things like we're remembering
a close person's phone number or a
street pattern or even the way that a
new technology is connecting to
something that you already previously
know about another field let's say and
then if you the more apt the more
variables you have in your worldview the
more perspectives that you're carrying
at the same time in your worldview the
easier it becomes for you to be able to
see the world from all these different
angles instead of just
one straight echo chamber of an angle
exactly exactly so the more you actually
have stored in your brain the easier
it's going to be for you to learn and
understand new things new concepts yeah
Chester who were you growing up that got
you interested in memory very good
question there so I you know just
growing up I often got the comment from
people I kept hearing a lot wow you have
a really good memory and back then I
didn't have really any sort of formal
methodology any sort of really elaborate
system or anything I guess I was just
naturally good basically at coming up
with a connection between something new
that I was trying to remember and
something that already new I just had my
own way of coming up coming up with
these associations and so people would
say wow you have a good memory of law
and then I was flipping channels one
night this was back in the year 2000 I
happened to catch a segment on ABC's
20/20 that evening news show there was a
segment on the United States memory
championship and it sparked my interest
because people had been telling me that
I had this good memory right so I became
interested but when I looked into what
the best people in the country were
scoring in these events memorizing
hundreds of names hundreds of digits
decks of playing cards in minutes I
quickly found out that although I had a
good memory I was nowhere near that
level so that's when I started doing all
of this research into what are really
some ways that people can go about
magnifying their memory ability and
eventually well what happened was I I
read everything I could find online
books did all sorts of research I played
around with many different techniques a
lot of it didn't work so well for me
personally I found what worked well for
me personally stuck to training myself
in that subset of techniques until
eventually I did win the US memory
championship and now as you know I've
spent the last ten plus years training
other people
around the world in the small subset of
techniques that I feel can benefit the
most in their career in their personal
life and also this is really hit a huge
for kids in school yes yes so huge the
younger that we are when we start taking
on challenges like these skill sets
I love the skill set of spaced
repetition is a really good one that
I've been using that you've been
teaching me also the story method
actually just to be completely blunt
Chester's skills that he taught me last
year a little over a year ago were
exactly why I was able to succeed as
well as I did on the TEDx San Francisco
talk that I gave because I used your
techniques to remember my key points I
painted really beautiful abstract
visuals that were massive in size to
that I added senses too I had a
beautiful story that I was spacing the
repetition of and then I was doing it
backwards as well also and then I so by
unlocking this in me you've also made it
easier for me to give presentations for
me to remember strings of things I told
you that I was driving down I was in the
passenger seat and I was with my uncle
and mother and my phone was off battery
was dead
and I had all these profound things that
I wanted to retain so I started doing
the story method and spaced repetition
and I remembered a string of 12
completely unique bits of information
that I was then able to when I arrived
and I was repeating it backwards in the
car as well I was able to write it down
crystal clear when I got back so cool
and so I I loved and to be able to get
this into into children playing ages and
also your story about about when you see
other people that are memorizing these
massive in minutes they're massive
they're memorizing randomly assorted
decks of cards yet long strings of
numbers long string of names Chester is
when he starts as talks is giving a
hundred people more than that even their
names one after the next by just hearing
their name one time but
or hands yeah in their hand Wow those
this is the capacity of the memory you
said ancient people were remembering
remembering massive pieces of like
spiritual texts and things like that
I mean the capacity is unlimited and we
like you said we have yet to we'll never
reach the full understanding maybe we
will yeah our memory limits yeah so wow
you know I'm so glad to hear that you've
been able to put this into practice and
find it really useful definitely what I
you know I try my best to get that
message out there it's that it's with
the right approach and just a little bit
of practice it really is amazing what
you can do in terms of remembering
things and memory is fundamental to
learning it is a fundamental part of
their learning process there's no
avoiding that so really improving your
ability to remember is going to have a
positive impact on many different
aspects of your career personal life
you'll find very situations definitely
for people in school it's it's it's
amazing what's possible and it's just
the right approach and a little bit of
training and practice and then did you
end up discovering the the story method
and spaced repetition how did you figure
out okay there's all these memory
champions all these memory techniques
here are the ones that are is it kind of
personalized like the ones that work
best for each person and then they kind
of really get good at those and then try
and win the championships with those and
teach other people those yeah so good
question there it you know what I have
been teaching other people for the last
ten years and what I ended up focusing
on how I came about to this set
curriculum that I would normally train
people in it's a wide variety of ways as
to how I ended up you know with what I
am teaching now it was all of that
research I had done in the early days
you know since the year 2000 and my own
personal experiences experimenting with
all of that and then also my experience
training other people for the last 10
plus years seeing what works
or different people in different
situations and just through my other
experiences and people that I've come
into contact with you know in my line of
work I I'm able to look you know I feel
very lucky blessed to come into contact
with amazing leaders in their field like
dr. gazali and then also I got flown out
at one I heard about spaced repetition
it's actually a well-known concept in
psychology right this concept of spaced
repetition as as it applies to learning
but I first heard about it when I was
actually flown out to Washington
University in st. Louis so they flew me
out there and did some memory
experiments on me for a few days along
with some jeopardy champions we were all
part of something called the superior
memory project at Wash U and in st.
Louis and while there I was talking with
the researcher said you know this is
what I do now I'm trying to train people
around the world how can I help students
with this in particular and they said
you know Chester it's with all of the
stuff that you've been teaching people
but add this concept of spaced
repetition and they were saying that you
know how students usually study for
exams is they'll just cram all of the
info in you know like the night before a
couple days before the exam that is only
good for short-term memory that's it so
cramming a bunch of like 2030 reviews
done today will allow you to spit it all
out on an exam but then it just
completely vanishes from your memory
you're right you've lost that but they
were telling me you know if students
after the lecture if they would review
right after the lecture then maybe a
week later than two weeks after that
then maybe a few weeks after that if
they space out their reviews it will
then lock into long-term memory
right so really the ideal way to get
things in a long term memory is with the
types of techniques that I teach in
conjunction with spaced repetition there
it's there are even some apps out there
that people may have heard of
that try to help you with this basically
the app will remind you probably when
you should do your next review yeah
right so that it's built around this
concept so it's a really well known
concept to help you more effectively put
things into long-term memory yeah and
the you can you can do something as
simple as you're at a an event where
you're learning information that you
think is really important to you the
number one thing that I get I guess
upset about when people are trying to
learn is that I asked them about like
are you gonna review this tonight or
you're gonna review this the next day
are you gonna review this because how
much do you actually care about what
you're learning because if you really
care about what you're learning you will
go and review it the next day you'll
practice trying to teach it to someone
else
yep you will revisit it the next week as
well because then that's how you can
actually hack into storing this
knowledge that you want to retain yeah
one kind I guess have hack that I can
that I should mention is one of those
reviews should come it's recommended
early on right before you go to sleep do
a review right before you go to sleep
because a lot of research has shown that
if you you review something soon before
sleep basically you're telling your
brain to process that your brain will
process the information overnight and
you will find that you wake up the next
morning you know it better than you did
the day before without having done any
additional reviews but it's because your
brain really turned that information
overnight it's one of the current
theories as to why we sleep so as of
today no one has the definitive answer
as to why humans sleep but some
researchers do believe that part of it
has to do with the consolidation of
important information into long-term
memory so that's part of what your brain
is doing overnight so do a review before
sleep of something important it's going
to help it get into the long-term memory
yeah
yeah wrong hey say that again what do I
need to do to work on this before I go
to sleep memory one of the great things
that you can do is when you go to before
you go to sleep is to think about the
things that you really learned that day
especially that you want to focus on
storing into and consolidating into with
your past life experience and that's one
of the big things about why we yeah so
just try to get into that habit this is
it's it's really easy for people to do
and it's amazing how just doing this one
thing well how much it will help and I
it's something I recommend for names so
when people come to me and their goal is
to really become better member in
people's names to get more out of
business networking to build better
relationships with people in general I
recommend that in addition to all the
techniques that I would teach make sure
that you're doing that before you go to
sleep so say you go to a party or you
had a meeting that day do a mental
run-through who was at that meeting
today right and then review their names
along with with the other techniques you
know I don't know if you want to get
into that again that the techniques for
names I had mentioned it in the last
interview all go through quickly now in
case people missed the first yeah so
techniques for names come up with a
visual that that's it's it's simple but
powerful and effective so if someone's
name is Mike maybe see a microphone if
the name is Jane I might visualize a
chain so there's a sound-alike
thing going on there Alice I might
visualize a white rabbit because that
would remind me of Alice and wonderland
there are various ways as to how the
image can remind you of the name but
come up with an image something you can
picture in your mind to remind you of
the name and then ideally you also want
to link that to the person's look so
let's say you're meeting someone named
Alice and to you this is just to you
personally what you notice about her
when you're meeting her is her hair you
think in your opinion she has really
beautiful
you might then imagine this white rabbit
jumping around in her hair or getting
tangled up in her hair okay so how this
works is the next time you see her you
ask yours all you have to ask yourself
is what what is noticeable to me about
her look if you had noticed the hair
before you're very likely to notice it
again and you'll be amazed instantly the
image of the white rabbit it's gonna
come right back because you've made that
connection in your brain so the white
rabbit is gonna come back to you and
that might remind you of the name Alice
so that's one way to do it it sounds a
little bit crazy maybe a little bit out
there but it's very powerful effective
anyone can get good with just a little
bit of practice I would recommend this
type of visual based technique there are
many others you know if you take a look
at my online stuff you can find other
techniques I won't get into too much
time I don't want to spend too much time
just on names but this is gonna be more
effective than other things you'll find
in business success books they don't
have actually they don't tend to have
very good techniques if they have part
of a chapter on names and they'll say
just repeat the name over and over to
yourself right they'll say imagine
writing the name in big print with the
marker on their forehead or they'll say
ask them you know how do you spell your
name Bob you know which would be silly
if it's a lot of common names that would
be dumb to ask them how to spell their
name but you know if those things help
you at all it's only gonna work in the
very short term all right because the
next time you see them you have nothing
to help you like you know there's
nothing to help queue up or pull up in
your mind the memory of the name but
what I teach you will be based on the
person's look so it's more effective the
next time you see the person yeah
yeah I love that one and and that adds
that visualization component to it and
also repeating their name immediately
after you meet them mentioning yeah I
had given you those steps last time I
don't want I didn't want to go over them
yeah but yeah just little things go a
long way in towards of mentor and you
know in terms of memory a little bit
years a long way yeah and to
continuously practice that too
let's do okay we did a demo of the list
of words which it's so funny that you
that I'm literally seeing the story
still of the words right now it's so
funny how just a random string still
like whatever it is 18 months later can
still be visually recalled like that
yeah it's it is amazing I get people
that will email me years after attending
one of my presentations and they're like
is this the list of words and they they
got it right it's just because what's
happening with these techniques that I
teach people is without realizing it you
were using so much of your brain to
encode the information into your memory
so let's let's do another demo but a
brand new one I love it that we didn't
do last time actually I have two in
minds for this interview some new stuff
so people that saw the first interview
will still get a lot of out of this one
as well hopefully that's my goal so
before we do that quickly I want to
review the main principles visualization
I just talked about in terms of names so
come up with the picture obviously names
but this will apply to anything at all
okay could be points from a presentation
and and so on second thing from there
add additional senses as you can write
so don't just see it are you smell the
pie exactly all right that you got it so
smell it imagine even tasting it get
some additional sentences because what's
happening there is when you do that
you're activating more areas of your
brain and you are building more
connections in your mind to that
information so it makes it easier to
retrieve the information when you need
it later right so that's the second
thing to keep in mind third is make that
all crazy unusual extraordinary in some
way
you're seeing it you're guiding these
additional senses involved and ends
remember to make it all crazy unusual
because there's a psychological aspect
human memory with no effort at all we
tend to remember things that catch us by
surprise that are strange and usual you
know I like to mention if wherever
you're watching this interview if an
elephant crashes into that room that
you're in right now and it starts to
spray water on you if that were to
really happen right now as you're
watching this for dinner you would never
forget you probably tell that story
every for the rest of your life you will
never believe this okay
I was watching that awesome simulation
series and they were interviewing some
memory guy when I was watching that
out of nowhere I'm not even joking with
you an elephant is crashing in the room
great watering me right that might be
stuck in your head forever without you
even trying to commit that to memory
whereas other times when you know it's
something important to remember you put
forth a lot of effort and you can't get
it into your long-term memory right but
the elephant just went in and in an
instant so that is knowing that there is
that aspect to how our mind works
realizing that we can take advantage of
it we can harness it and we can actually
apply it to presentations names foreign
language vocabulary exam material and so
on but we just have to realize that and
try to incorporate it into what we're
doing so we're gonna build a story this
is called the story method I want for
you to try to commit to memory first I'm
just gonna rattle off the words and then
I'm gonna work you through the exercise
so this word lists different than before
this one will be cloud bicycle elephant
watermelon cat egg rabbit mud bird
whistle jungle turkey sword computer and
pizza okay now usually you know without
any sort of memory training or knowledge
in ways to improve your ability remember
things when presented with that list
people are just like their mind is you
know wanting to explode they're like
there's no way I'm gonna remember that
not unless you give me a lot of time to
do it but as you
when you use the right approach the
right technique we're gonna we're gonna
commit that to memory in about three
minutes that's it should take about
three minutes and then everyone watching
this they can fall along and they'll be
able to recite the words hopefully
forwards and backwards believe it or not
so just have fun with this all right see
what I describe to you as best you can
all right so visualization yeah so we
had the cloud was first so just
visualize this giant cloud whatever that
looks like for you all right
falling out of the cloud is a bicycle
right falls out of the cloud it's
falling down super unusual yes falling
out out out it's falling down towards
the earth this bicycle the bicycle hits
the ground it starts just going along by
itself the bicycle right just going
along by itself the bicycle the bicycle
smashes into an elephant alright I like
elephants I guess smashes into an
elephant picture that alright
spinning on the back of the elephant is
a giant watermelon
there's a giant watermelon II all right
and exploding out of the watermelon a
cat a cat explodes out of the watermelon
alright the cat now runs and crashes
into an egg crashes into an egg
alright the egg cracks open and a rabbit
jumps out and starts hopping around this
rabbit starts hopping her out okay
picture that the rabbit hops into a huge
pile of mud alright hops into some mud
and it splatters all over the places mud
the mud starts to splatter onto a bird
the mud starts to splatter onto a bird
maybe see this crazy-looking bird
alright and the bird is blowing a
whistle
the bird is blowing a whistle
it drops the whistle into a jungle it
drops a whistle into this giant jungle
and there is a turkey you see this
turkey just wandering around the jungle
you're like what is a turkey doing
wandering around in this jungle alright
see the turkey the turkey starts to play
around somehow I can't explain how it's
doing it just use your imagination it's
playing with the sword the sword goes
through a computer screen just right
through the face of the computer screen
and out the back of the computer comes a
pizza now you're hungry one you want to
eat that pizza or maybe you start to eat
the pizza even so that was it I'm just
gonna quickly review that you'll just
replay through this little story so we
started out with that giant cloud what
fell out of it bicycle the bicycle crash
into what elephant what was spinning on
the back of the elephant lawn watermelon
what exploded out of it was a cat the
cat crashed into the egg what cracked
out of the egg it was a rabbit the
rabbit jumped into the mud the mud was
splattering on the bird the bird was
blowing a whistle it dropped the whistle
into the jungle what was wandering
around the jungle a turkey the turkey
started to play with the sword which
went through the computer and the pizza
fell out of the back right so now Alan
and people watching this can follow
along do their best to give those random
words go ahead in order all right let's
see so cloud bicycle elephant watermelon
cat
egg rabbit mud bird whistle jungle
turkey sword computer pizza 100% man you
guys are awesome nice under pressure I
know it's not what we don't always have
guests on they're gonna like put you
through a brain exercise like that and
test you on the spot in three minutes
like yeah I didn't I don't know how long
exactly we took but probably it was a
few minutes or so and that was that was
15 random or 15 random words locked and
just like that and again people that
were following longer than defined even
from a month from now they might still
know those forwards and backwards
without ever even reviewing it again
because you are using so much of your
brain when you're using these techniques
without realizing just there as soon as
you are like envision this cloud know of
a sudden a bicycle Falls from Earth I
mean like literally the more crazy like
you said that outliers these more crazy
things it crashes into an elephant right
or the other one was that the turkey is
holding a sword right you know the more
outlier these things are yeah out of the
back of the computer falls a pizza yeah
so that these things are so abstractly
different than normal life like the
elephant crashing toward the law of the
room and spraying you with water yeah
that you commit them faster yep yeah so
that's an important principle to always
keep in mind when you are using these
sorts of memory techniques and there
there are all sorts of other techniques
I'm on my website I have something new
brand-new this year I never I've never
had it in previous years I launched an
online memory school I like to call it
because what it provides you with is
some core training that used to be like
eh to sell that as one course it's the
equivalent of that course core training
then you have advanced training that you
can go through after that and then it's
ongoing training every month new videos
that I upload every month in it that
it's a video training my course before
used to be like an audio you're
listening to it and then you'd fall
along the website so this is via
high-definition videos video tutorials
so it's a really cool memory school and
you'll learn
other techniques many other techniques
but the one important principle that you
always apply is that psychological
aspect to memory I wanted to go through
a brand new exercise we didn't do one
like this last time well it's similar to
that one but there's there's a little
difference here I want to do it because
I want to impress upon people the fact
that you know this stuff doesn't just
apply to you know an elephant and a
watermelon and a cat right this applies
to even it can be complex types of
information it can be points from a
presentation this can be helping you
learn the difference between one concept
and another one there's similar concepts
but you have these two things make them
different right remembering that sort of
stuff I was a speaker I think you know I
don't I don't know if I mentioned it in
the last interview but you you you know
my background so I've even they had me
at Harvard you know to the Harvard
Graduate Council you can see a
testimonial on my website where they're
talking about how I had the graduate
students going through this sort of
stuff so Harvard Business students law
students medical students it can be
complex types of information as well
this exercise will show you how it's not
just a elephant in a watermelon so
you're gonna visualize Allen some giant
machines alright okay
so we'll just take about one minute this
one giant machines whatever that looks
like to you and these giant machines
smash up a huge pile of gold and silver
alright
gold and silver okay rising up out of
the gold and silver vehicles whatever
that image looks like tu vehicles are
shooting out of the windows of the
vehicles medicine okay and exploding out
of the medicine oil maybe you know
petroleum oil black the black oil that
will be easiest to visualize that was it
man I'm gonna go through this again
you've got these giant machines they
were smashing up the gold and silver
what rose up vehicles watch out of the
windows vehicles it was medicine what
exploded out of Medicine it was oil
alright this was quick and easy give it
a try yeah yeah okay so the machines the
gold and silver the cars the medicine
the oil you got it man now
yeah that was it that was the whole
exercise so what you did there without
realizing it or maybe you did I'm not
sure what we did there is we tricked
people into memorizing the top five
exports of the UK so even the Trump yeah
so if you were to look that up right now
what people would find if they looked it
up listed as the UK's top exports it
will say machinery precious metals
vehicles pharmaceuticals and oil so that
exercise gives you an idea of how what
we're basically doing here is we're
building just mental note cards mental
cue cards just basically what you would
write down on a you know on a short list
of notes instead you're building these
note cards in your brain so that when
you meet with clients potential clients
are presentation in front of colleagues
you have command of this information
people are like wow you know Alan knows
his stuff obviously Alan you know know
something about this area right whereas
again what I like to stress cuz I know
people will probably write this in the
comments I get it all time oh well you
know these days you don't need to
remember stuff right maybe you don't
maybe you wouldn't need to remember that
in meeting with the client potential
client or if you're giving a
presentation yeah you could have that
all on the slide and just read it off
the slide it's not needed but you're
gonna be like 99% of other people out
there whereas nowadays you really have
an opportunity to be more impressive
Yeah right
if because nowadays nobody's remembering
anything so if you actually committed
that to memory you are really better
able to demonstrate your expertise the
impression is gonna be Wow you know Alan
really knows this stuff and you're gonna
be more memorable to people more
impressive and more memorable yeah when
I just hope the kids hear this yeah yeah
you kids three kids really because when
the vast majority of people are
conforming to using the these appendages
and storing the data there and when you
take this new path of really mastering
these memory skills
you are an outlier than in the world
exactly because you can just be you hero
it's funny at an event just literally be
like do you know what the top five
exports are of the United Kingdom
well actually I can walk you through a
really beautiful story of remembering
how to do machines precious metals cars
pharmaceuticals oil and if you can carry
that mental note card with you imagine
now how many mental note cards can we
carry with us about the complex world
that we live in
then those mental note cards instead of
because I'm an avid note-taker and I
gotta remind myself frequently and I
told you this last time is that I gotta
remember sometimes that I really need to
take certain things that I'm storing
into the appendages of computers and
rather try and remember that string of 5
7 10 12 items that can then be a mental
note card that I can pull any time
because I've closed my eyes I've
imagined a complex beautiful visual with
added senses that are outliers scenarios
these types of things
Chester this is critical yeah it it can
be so useful in many different ways in
it as I hope people realize it isn't
hard to do a little bit goes a long way
it can help you to make that can help to
make you more memorable there are so
many ways that this can benefit you I've
been one thing I've been working on
since the last time I was here I started
working more on my social media so I
have been filming one minute tips every
week posting them to LinkedIn I think
you have my LinkedIn link in the in the
notes Twitter and also Instagram so
Chester J Santos is my Twitter it's also
my Instagram as well
I'll post every week or maybe sometimes
it'll be every other week depending on
what's going on with me in terms of my
speeches and presentations that week but
tips from all over the world and I will
talk about how that location
in some way relates to memory one that I
posted from Venice Italy it's the
birthplace of Casanova so we've all
heard of Casanova the world's greatest
lover right so in researching him I
didn't know this before I did the
research apparently he was very charming
to both men and women people found him
very interesting very charming be
courtly because of his vast knowledge
from so many different areas right so
there are stories written about him that
describe his incredible memory ability
he just can learn he could learn things
very quickly and this helped you know to
make him a more charming guy another
thing I mentioned I haven't posted this
one yet the full tip you'll get a
preview in this interview
I'll post one from Verona Italy about
you know the importance Shakespeare you
know Romeo and Juliet the setting is
Rona I'll talk about how just you know
having some interesting quotes committed
to memory it just makes you more
interesting in conversations right so
there's just a couple more examples
there again as I opened the interview
today within this technology very
technology driven society I think we
need to be aware that there still is a
lot of value in developing human beings
right personal development they're still
really is a lot of value in it and it
can I think nowadays maybe more than
ever at least more than any other time
in the last few decades it can really
benefit you because everyone's just
turning off their brains so if you can
demonstrate that you have some skills
yeah it's it's impressive to take an
example like Casanova and see the what
could have potentially been just this
this relentless a desire to take what
was this these profound inputs that the
experiencing into mental note cards and
storing those across different fields
and being able to recall those mental
note cards and impress people that way
um can totally separate you from the
crowd
some memory school is something that
people can do at their own pace through
your well yeah that's another great
thing about it is you know the first two
courses and I used to sell those as
completely separate courses how I have
it set up right now because it's
brand-new and I'm kind of you know we'll
see what it ends up being priced at
later but for now although you get
instant access to those courses there's
no I'm not charging at the moment an
enrollment or setup fee
I might later because I'm giving you
access to those courses right away that
I used to charge one hundred hundreds of
dollars for but right now no setup fee
and there's a free trial as well so you
can check it out see if you like it
think see if you're benefiting from it
and then after the trial is up it's only
ten dollars a week so it's $40 a month
really its peanuts basically in terms
comparing that to what how you're gonna
benefit in your career and personal life
and definitely if you have kids in
school yeah sign them up I don't want to
separate and the masses yeah and memory
skills yeah definitely so yeah check it
onto my website memory school oh this
has been so interesting thinking about
all the cool things that we can actually
commit to memory I mean the UK export
list was was one of the just most
profound like awareness expansions for
me because it's now thinking about you
know this list of you know we are was
just studying some you know like
American literature and some of these
important poets and authors in American
literature and I was wondering like well
how can I commit people like Walt
Whitman and TSLA how can I commit these
people to my memory more easily like the
Four Quartets that TS Eliot wrote write
how can I commit these things more
easily to memory or like or something
like the the Nobel Prize winner
list and what they achieved right things
that these things that are important for
us to remember but that we that we
frequently write into the technological
devices sometimes we just look at it and
then never try and commit it yeah
sometimes we take it and put it in the
device to try and remember it but how
can I look at that information and store
it in one of these beautiful mental note
cards that I can then recall this list
of Nobel laureates yeah and something
like that that would be so cool and and
also to know because these are profound
moments for society that have unlocked a
lot of peace or a lot of prosperity in
the sciences or literature yeah so then
okay we talked about this a little bit
at the beginning but I want to know a
little bit more on like there's a word
here it's mnemonics the systems to
improve a memory I think I love this
word mnemonics and that's kind of what
you've been teaching these different
mnemonic systems and we kind of talked
about the neuroscience a little bit now
you did the BBC World News you did that
that was a cool way of trying to take
this to like a hundred million people
are the importance of memory you've been
also doing corporate events and stuff
and like you said you were in Italy
doing these short bits to some people
yeah so that's something I did in just
the last couple of months it was I would
say my biggest TV appearance ever
because it turns out that BBC World News
is the most watched news channel in the
world I didn't know that but when they
asked me to be on they pitched me on
that like this is a good opportunity so
I guess they have 120 million viewers in
over 200 countries and they had me on
they wanted me to come on and talk about
the importance of memory skills to
success in business nowadays so I talked
about names which we covered earlier I
hit a bit on the you know facts and
figures to demonstrate your expertise
and I did what I felt was kind of are
well you guys can try to find the
tips online and see if you find a
humorous but I was bringing up cuz Game
of Thrones was big at that time when I
was doing the interview everybody's
watching the last season of gaming a
game of Thrones so I tried to tie that
in a little bit there so I talked about
how well I brought up a real world
example too but from Game of Thrones
Daenerys you know the Dragon Queen
Daenerys Targaryen she was able to speak
all those different languages right and
the places she was visiting the peoples
that she conquered or liberated she was
communicating with them on the show
always in their own language so that
really helped to increase her rapport
and help to make her a more effective
and charismatic leader but then I also
tied it to real life and that is the
real world example this was in my
1-minute tips series from Milan Italy in
front of the Milan Cathedral apparently
that's where Napoleon was crowned the
king of Italy and then in researching
Napoleon I found out that you'll read a
lot of stories about him and his amazing
memory ability so he could remember the
names of apparently thousands of
soldiers believe it or not and he could
instantly memorize Maps for instance so
his memory ability really gave it built
reports of soldiers but also gave them
more confidence in him and his abilities
yeah so this can be a really memory
skills can be a really important
leadership skill as well so that's what
I you know the interview was like a
couple of minutes or something they give
you in one of these news shows but
that's what I some of what I hit on
during my my interview yeah whoa think
about if you can yeah remember the names
of the people that are involved with
what you're you know working on if you
can remember things like a like a like a
vision that you have for the
organization and if you can keep that
store that a memory people will believe
in you more as a leader yeah it's great
to see the news outlets that have a
great amount of viewers
care more about teaching things like
this and not just propagating fear
that's so important okay
teach us about on the we hit this at the
very beginning I want to make sure that
this is kind of talked about regarding
our future we're going to the 2020s
we're seeing the technology just get
smaller the computing capacity get
faster do you bik WA T of it get
widespread what how do we as as still
biological beings yeah
function well in the exponential
technology hodgepodge of mayhem that's
happening yeah so we really just need to
be aware of it you know that's why I'm
really we've known each other a while
now it was it's been a little bit more
of the focus of my message during
presentations I used to not hit on it as
much but I'm really just trying to
stress get across this message that
there is a danger in digital dependency
I think we just need to be aware of it
and realize that our brain your brain is
your most valuable and most important
business asset all right that there's no
getting around that your brain is your
most important asset and we need to make
sure that we're in there the heart to
you know brain brain and heart yeah
brain brain heart is important you
really can't do anything else right
develop any other skills without the
power of your brain your brain power
your mind power and it's we're losing
our brain power mind power when we're
just we're not using it to do anything
anymore when we let the devices do
everything for us I think that we can
find a little bit of a better balance so
for instance like the case with phone
numbers ice I enter the numbers into my
phone as well and ice I encourage people
to do that but I'm just saying why not
why not also commit them to memory
right and when you need especially for
close friends and family members there's
really no excuse for using the auto dial
for them right just make
effort to dial those numbers remember
yeah it's gonna feel like work I
understand that all right but how do you
build up your biceps you have to go in
the gym and it feels like work and a lot
of times we don't want to do it right
and like we're like do I really know but
you really that is what is necessary to
grow your muscles right it's the same
thing with your brain you know you need
to exercise your brain you need to use
it in order to really keep it strong
right and develop that brain power that
mind power so I just hope that people
will start to become more aware of this
and when they can when the occasion
arises especially like phone numbers
just make that effort use your brain a
little bit don't just completely turn
your brain off because I feel like
people are really turning their brains
off when they don't need to and again
maybe in a couple of decades I think
it's more dr. ghazzal ease area them in
my area but I know he's talking about
that we're in a cognition crisis right
so we're probably gonna find out in the
coming decades what what really the
negative results what the negative
impact is of us just completely
outsourcing everything to technology I
always want to acknowledge that
technology beautiful technology's good
it solves a lot of problems it helps us
but let's just not lose touch that yeah
we are biological creatures right like
let's not lose touch with that and that
we need to work on our personal
development as well yeah I think Jamie
will on our show called it don't be a
dopamine monkey Oh interesting oh yeah
from the when you get a message
supposedly the dopamine goes off yeah
yeah or even the very like the variable
rewards and the yeah and the feeds and
the comments and likes yeah it likes on
your foot all that's and verses yeah
being able to do something as simple as
just commit something profound that you
find interesting about the world took
your memory commit it to your own memory
and not devices such a good action item
Chester I don't think we asked you this
one last time so I want to ask you this
where do you what do you think happens
before birth and what do you think
happens after death okay
definitely not my area yeah so you know
before birth
what is related I guess to to what I'm
doing is I mean I've I'm not an expert
in that field or anything but that there
are things that apparently you're you
know the mother is listening to music or
something you know the baby can somehow
process that in the womb and it might
help brain development you know I don't
know I I but I'm I find that area a
little I find it pretty interesting
actually you know that maybe there are
things going on in the womb there
outside stimulus that can affect our
growth and our development so I think
that's an interesting area to to look
into more that's the best I'm gonna
answer that what happens before we're
born and then at what happens after
death
I don't know man I have a ghost story I
don't want to tell the ghost story now
but I didn't believe in ghosts at all
but I feel like I did actually see one
at one point and that's all that's up
for debate so I think maybe that what I
will say on this what I can say more
confident with me since this isn't my
area at all is that I do think there are
things that we just don't understand
supernatural yeah there are things that
we just don't understand that we don't
really have an attic science can't
as of today can't really give you an
adequate explanation some people or even
think that we come from somewhere beyond
the physical plane to take the seat in
these bodies and I think that's very
interesting as well that can be explored
better and that we potentially go back
to yeah well my job is asking questions
yeah I think there's really I think
there's a lot that we just don't fully
understand you know that that it'll be
interesting to explore more in in the
future and then I think we asked you but
let's see if you have have an update do
you think we're in a simulation you
asked me that before I still don't think
we're in assume you still don't think so
okay yeah that's just my opinion
I still don't think we are yeah I just
don't it's my I don't think we're in a
simulation that's a good way to play a
game that's where that's what I agree
why not
stop asking these questions and then I
think we asked you what do you think's
the most beautiful thing in the world
hmmm such a hard question
I guess you know human beings in general
just the human experience is very
beautiful you know I you know I was
talking about the mind you were talking
about the heart but both I'm always
amazed with just a lot of times I find
myself completely amazed at everything
that humans are capable of you know on
so many even just like dance like I try
to go to the San Francisco Ballet
opening night every year and it always
just blows my mind like the whole you
know the the skill level and just the
beauty of it all but not just dance but
I like America's Got Talent that show a
lot just to see the amazing talents that
people have you know developed you know
the works of art literature but also
technology like it blows my mind how the
heck am i watching like any movie that's
ever been created I can watch it in
almost instantly now you know or any
song like you know Alexa play this song
and it just starts playing like it's
just we're live on two platforms or you
live in the world to see the fact that
that's happening that you know we're
live right now all over the world it's
just it's mind-blowing what humans have
been able to accomplish in so many
different areas it's it's just it's it's
a beautiful thing fan yeah yeah I love
that chest is such a good answer and
then I also wonder on where on the terms
of memory could potentially things you
know people say the body keeps the score
so could it potentially be that some of
these memories these emotional
experience that we have do they get
stored in the heart or in the gut do
they get stored in other areas on
besides the central nervous system
who knows yeah I don't know that these
are interesting questions again
potentially for like dr. Ezeli and
others yeah yeah Wow awesome Chester I
feel like we did super well thank you so
much for coming
Thank You Man it was a pleasure and you
know I I love it thanks for having me on
again you're super welcome we love
having you on Ches we're excited to do
another episode with you down the line
as things keep going we got to practice
more of the techniques that you were
teaching us in this episode we hope that
others that were watching please
practice these memory techniques your
memory skills are a great way to
separate yourself in the exponential
technology age practice these things
like the story method the spaced
repetition get going with practicing
this is sharing it with your friends
your family's co-workers people online
social media gets sharing these things
and check out the links in the bio again
- Chester Santos comm is LinkedIn and
Twitter profiles his book down there
also go and check out his memory school
get involved in the memory school get
practicing again with these techniques
shout out to Ron Vargas for producing
and directing thank you very much Ronnie
and also support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations the
spiritual leaders around the world that
you believe and support simulation our
links are below
supports paypal patreon on our
cryptocurrency links below also design
cool merch and get paid for join us
support us grow and go and build the
future everyone we're gonna end with
more of Chester's awesome soundtrack
manifest your dreams at the world thanks
for tuning in we'll see you soon
peace
[Music]
[Music]